addiction one of the greatest faces of
our civilized world takes many forms
drugs booze sex the list goes on in the
world of Fallout falls prey to
addictions wretched claws just as we do
especially at the commonwealth's of
vault 95 looking like just another
gunner outpost on the outside vault 95
resides in the southwestern quadrant of
the Commonwealth find it and you'll have
to blast your way through a standard
gunner unit equipped with lasers rifles
and assault drones once you break
through the initial guard force hop into
an elevator and head into the main vault
fall 95 in standard fallout vaults eight
horribly decrepit and run down even
though this one has a living population
I guess the Gunners can't really be
bothered to pick up a couple of pieces
of trash even if it's where they sleep
after taking out another large
encampment of Gunners the main hub of
all 95 will be yours to explore all of
the other corridors and rooms of the
vault branch out of this main area so it
makes sense that the overseers room
looks over the section in the overseas
room you can see the first hints of what
happened to the residents of vault 95
what's surprising in this room is that
there are a lot of residential skeletons
in it not really the kind of privacy and
seclusion that we typically find in
overseers rooms and other halls also the
skeletons bodies being set up in a
circle of chairs looks oddly like an
Alcoholics Anonymous meeting the
overseers terminal in the corner should
give some more insight into the workings
of how the people of all 95 lived or
maybe even what it all takes experiment
in this vault was looking inside it you
can see that vault 95 was set up to be a
democracy where everyone votes on what
they want to happen the vault and even
on who the overseer named overseer elect
in this vault should be additionally the
terminal shows that the members of vault
95 are indeed all addicted to some
substance and then the vault plan is for
them to attend meetings to help work
through their addiction is vault-tec
actually trying to help people overcome
their addiction so far vault 95 doesn't
look all that evil but then again this
is vaulteq we're dealing with not really
the shining beacon of morality in the
Fallout universe the terminal is also
able to open a master lock door to the
facility's wing one of the two main
wings of the vault however the other
wing the residential is the harbor of
the history and story of the vault that
we seek heading on into the
or Gunners are eager to be disposed of
but you can also start to see some
alcoholic beverages and Kem's around
vodka whiskey buff out of medics are the
Gunners these big of junkies their
militaristic attributes was make a scene
like they'd be too strict to be this
heavy into addictive substances but the
only others who could have been using
these were the residents of all 25 back
when it was first in use how and why
would a vault about curing people's
addictions come across all these highly
addictive alcohols and camps the
terminal around the area might offer
some much-needed explanation signing
into the terminal you can see it's
assigned to 1r Gutierrez and some great
knowledge can be attained from the files
on the terminal seems that Gutierrez had
some secret orders from Baltic he was to
assume the disguise of a normal vault
dweller and fulfill this role for five
calendar years after this time Gutierrez
was ordered by vault Tec to open a
secret cache of every cam and alcohol of
the residents of fault 95 desperately
wish to avoid he was then to document
the response of the community following
their discovery of the stash it seems
that Gutierrez had no qualms with this
plan because even though he acknowledged
that every member of the vault had
overcome their addiction when there was
no alternative a hole in the wall very
similar to what he described in his
terminal can be found a few metres away
and it's stashed with every addictive
substance imaginable in the fallout
universe there's vodka there's whiskey
psycho Mentats beer buffout radaway
radix whatever the residents of vault 95
wanted to avoid for the rest of their
lives is right here in plenty and it
seems that some of the vault dwellers
couldn't resist the room adjacent to the
cache a Kem's are littered with
substances and skeletons it seems that
many of the members of the vault
couldn't resist their vices and
succumbed to them the skeleton in the
showers favored vodka one another
bathroom psycho the room of two wanted a
lot of both psycho and jet the last
resident in the area got a fixham psycho
and jet plus whatever he or she could
fit into the aluminum canister beside
the dead body the decayed bodies
surrounded in alcohols Kem's or both
paint a picture of relapse and overdose
resulting in death from multiple
unfortunate residents of vault 95 yeah
one of the skeletons in the area is
complete
drug and alcohol free directly outside
of the hole the skeleton is lying on the
ground with only a 10 mil pistol beside
it it appears that this resident
committed suicide once they realized the
contents of the stash choosing death
over a life even in the presence of cans
and alcohols perhaps the resident knew
that they wouldn't be able to resist the
clutches of addiction like the others in
the neighboring rooms and decided a
bullet to the brain was better than a
life spent addicted or a death from
overdose a little farther away from the
stash and through a couple additional
Gunners eyes a room barricaded from the
inside out looks like one of the vault
residents chose to take a stand against
addictions when the camphor released
signing on to the terminal in the room
you can see into the mind of one Jay
Scott as it was when the devil of
addiction was released into the vault
scott records that gun shots were fired
saying that others were fighting
probably over who gets which Kem's and
alcohol although the shots could have
been caused by a variety of things
someone in the overseers room could have
shot everybody in the room during one of
their AAA meetings a possible cause as
to why they all died in their chairs
possibly multiple suicides around the
vault occurred maybe a members started
shooting others who chose to use again
trying to stop addiction from taking
control of the whole vault following an
understandable resentment for vaulteq
can be seen in Scott's logs he realized
that this was all part of the plan to
research and document the phenomena of
addiction and how live humans react to
different aspects of it and he cursed
vaulteq for their immorality and
crewless through the later logs
Scott's will can be seen breaking down
eventually completely collapsing at
Scott giving up on staying away from
drugs and just wanting to be with his
friends hoping that quote somebody's
left we could only assume the worst for
Scott and the others the bowels of vault
95 continued the sad story of
destruction and death that we have seen
so far near the reactor lies one of the
most concentrated pits of substances and
death scene away from the stash buffout
alcohol and medics they scattered among
the bodies perhaps these were close
friends and they all just got carried
away in the high of their relapse losing
their lives in the process maybe they
really didn't take lethal dose of Kem's
and be near the reactor so now triggered
a deadly reaction they could have even
been hiding away from the temptations
that they knew that they
couldn't resist only to have some
unwanted guests bring these harbingers
of death to them through one way or
another unfortunately we can only guess
as to what happened the truth may always
lie in a mystery but it is assuredly a
depressing and tragic tale heading back
on up to the vault proper one other
major wing is lack the facilities wing
which tells less of what happened in the
fall of all 95 and more of what the
residents would have wanted to happen
after fighting through the final and
lead gunner division as suggested by the
master lock door a glimpse into the more
positive side of the vault can be seen
even though they have now been riddled
with gunner abuse and the substances
which wrought the destruction of the
vault the cafeteria offices classroom
and detox room speak to the day-to-day
life of the dwellers overcoming
addiction and trying to live the most
normal and best lives that they could
given their circumstances the people of
this vault like almost any other were
just trying to survive and make sense of
the turmoil that had taken over their
planet this may have even been one of
the more optimistic vaults due to the
nature of the people that it was
comprised of rather than fret over the
loss of society as they knew it they
carried the mindset that his fault life
had given them a new beginning a chance
to start over as Scott put it in his
Terra mental but vault-tec seized all
that from the residents to try and
further its own knowledge at the expense
of human lives this time with concerns
to addiction it's kind of funny kind of
morbid to to think that an entire vault
of people was lost trying to gain better
insight into a problem that has been
answered by relatively cheap solution in
the modern day Commonwealth addiction of
any and every kind can be cured by one
trip to most any doctor and at a fairly
cheap price - there could be a chance
that something vault-tec learned in
vault 95 helped further the progress
that eventually culminated at this
resolution but the chances are gravely
slim the only thing that can be CERN is
the demise of the residents of vault 95
as a quick aside I just wanted to note
the abundance of enamel buckets in this
vault enamel paint most likely being the
empty content of them almost every
single section of the vault has a couple
of these white buckets or just plain old
paint buckets and this is important to
note because paint although generally
only spray paint is a method in which
some people use to get high huffing
spray paint is an incredibly intense
bizarre fun and long-lived high that's
not even remotely worth it as one
retired user put it in the huge amount
of this in an addiction centered vault
is almost assuredly not a coincidence
members of vault 95 had yet another
substance along with the more
conventional Kem's and alcohol which
might have been available as tempting
the whole time they occupied the vault
that sucks
you